no one can live here anymore the
Ukrainian Air Force has been bombing
mariinka a suburb of Donetsk for two
days now people are desperate to get out
most are heading towards the Russian
border but some are seeking refuge with
relatives in the center of Donetsk
residents like svetlana panteleyev and
her children the bomb attacks were
absolutely awful I can't even put it
into words
they've been blowing up her houses I'm
just grateful that we were brought out
Donetsk has become a flashpoint in the
conflict along with Luhansk it's one of
the last strongholds of the pro-russian
separatists the Ukrainian military has
surrounded both cities and has pounded
them with airstrikes just over the
border in Russia a man was killed by a
shell fired from the Ukrainian side
Moscow said it was a deliberate
provocation and threatened retaliation
this has added to the tension Kiev
denies any responsibility supporting the
Britain yeah we are not attacking
neighboring countries the separatists
fired across the border themselves in
order to provoke a Russian attack in
Washington a hastily arranged meeting
between German Chancellor Angela Merkel
and Russian President Vladimir Putin
demonstrates how pressurized the
situation has become they met shortly
before the World Cup final in Brazil and
agreed that direct negotiations between
the Ukrainian government and the
separatists leadership were necessary
but right now on the ground dialogue
seems a long way away the Ukrainian army
is continuing its attacks in the east
and people are fleeing the fighting